okay wir sind hier bei
ok und es geht wieder um unsere
community konzert und die nächsten
starts sind the black pony und sie
kommen zu euch in euer mal gucken was
müsste er machen wenn ihr wollt dass wir
bei euch spielen postet einfach ein bild
von dem zimmer eurem haus eurem garten
oder im partykeller einfach irgendwo ein
bild wo ihr richtig abgehen volt und
postet es auf der seite facebook.com /
klicks und ja dann setzen wir uns
zusammen und suchen das beste raus genau
da wo es ganz wichtig ist das muss auch
in berlin sein stimmt das hätte ich
jetzt wieder fast vergessen und aber es
können noch also die freunde natürlich
von demjenigen wo das ganze stattfindet
können dabei sein aber auch ein paar
andere leute und die müssen folgen
diesmal ja dafür müsst ihr folgende
frage beantworten und zwar wie viele
songs sind auf unserem album launched in
the pool die antwort schickt ihr einfach
anklicken mail.com genau und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen das
ganze soll stattfinden im mai war das
genau dann seid ihr alle hier ne genau
so und wir drücken alle die daumen wenn
ich sagen